ross stripling who has really thrown the
ball well lately will make the start
tonight yes he has 10th start of the
season for ross stripling pitched much
better than his stat line indicates in
his last start that was against the red
sox he was charged with four and runs in
five and two-thirds innings but two of
those runs came after he left the ball
game he had his highest strikeout game
with six since may the 24th when he
punched out seven tampa bay rays in
seven innings the mayhew's at third
judge at second tours at first so here's
giancarlo stanton
that one is ripped into right field
caught there by biggio
tagging is le mayhew he'll score easily
and it's a sac fly for stanton the other
runners stay put on nothing else you see
stanton just kind of muscle this
fastball in the inner half the other way
and that is garrett cole on the hill
tonight in buffalo you can see it'll be
his 14th start on the year those 81 and
two-thirds innings are
close to the top in the american league
and the walks wow only 11 walks and 113
strikeouts unheard of demarcus simeone
it's 1-0 to the blue jays lead-off man
samia hitting 290 for the season and
this one is smoke left field get out of
here ball
god
marcus simon gets things started in a
big way
a lead off home run for simeon and just
like that the blue jays have indicted
marcus has always talked about being
able to get on the fastball if you can
get ready and hit a good fastball
then you know your timing is coming
around you're going to be able to wait
just a little bit longer on a breaking
ball if you can turn around a fastball
and that's exactly what he did against
garrett cole's got one of the best
fastballs
in all of baseball i'll tell you what
marcus took a nice easy swing on that
inside basketball group nato adore the
second baseman will lead things up for
the yankees
goes after the high fastball swings and
misses first strike out of the game for
ross stripling that's how you use that
high fastball effectively throw it where
the hitter sees it it's the closest
pitch to his eyes so he thinks he can
hit it a long way but it's a tough pitch
to come up with well here is kyla
gasciouca the catcher well there's a
good slider from stripling back-to-back
strikeouts here in the second and he's
retired five in a row we've seen the
fastball we've also noticed that his
curveball's pretty good he'll throw his
share of sliders number nine hitter
brett gardner
there's another slider for the strikeout
how about that
he strikes out the side in the second
inning one ball two strikes martin with
the lead at first
not running anna ball is popped in here
shallow center field and gritsid makes a
diving catch he had to close ground on
it
but that'll end the top of the fifth
brando grichik with a fine defensive
play in center and here's kevin biggio
they count one and one
breaking ball hit high in the air to
left center gardner on the run at the
track out the wall gone home run for
kevin bizio that ball kept carrying out
to left field his last three home runs
have been opposite field home runs for
vizio that's his sixth of the season
second career home run against garrett
cole derrick cole thought that he was
going to trick him he fell behind
two-and-oh with fastballs and said okay
i'm going to trick him i'm going to
throw him a breaking ball but gavin said
you're not going to do that to me stayed
back on that ball nicely and took it out
the other way that's been impressive
swing from biggio since he's come off
the injured list 2-1 blue jays here's
guerrero with one
out guerrero jr much more selective than
his father
father who swung at everything and hit
everything and this is a good change up
at 92 miles an hour
there's the grip
there's the sink down right over the
heart of the plate out of the zone and
guerrero right over the top of it now
cole who's a high strikeout pitcher
that's just his second strikeout we're
in the sixth inning three balls two
strikes two outs
swing and a miss
richard gone on strikes no runs no hits
one error one man left we'll go to the
seventh in buffalo two one toronto now
gary sanchez is gonna come up and here's
the three one
that one's hit deep to left field there
it goes
see ya a
two-run home run for gary sanchez and
the yankees lead three to two
oh that gary is scary he hits a two-run
blast out of the ballpark and the
yankees take a 3-2 lead and that's what
happens when you try and aim pitches you
could see him trying to not pitch around
gary but he probably says don't give him
any don't lock him but don't give him
anything to hit you can't pitch like
that
and you could see he was trying to aim
it in the right spot and he missed and
also gary saw what he was trying to do
but that it was in the same parking lot
hopefully another car didn't get it that
was as they say hit a fur piece garrett
cole and gary sanchez had a good inning
it looks like cold's just talking
strategy there talking about reading
bats making adjustments on the fly and
garrett cole's one of the best in the
game of doing that at reading bats and
talking about pitch selection it's
really what it's about the pitcher
catcher relationship is really about
being on the same page
two outs going on and he's just a strike
away from emptying the tank
[Applause]
chop third base charging or shot fires
the first got him nice play by the
yankee third baseman and a one two three
inning for garrett cole who's retired
the last seven in a row gets a nice hand
from the yankee fans in buffalo so
another nail biter for the yankees
bottom of the ninth inning second and
third nobody out the 3-2
right back to chapman
they've got guerrero in a rundown he
dodged back but he's tagged out by
hershela for the second out they point
to the dugout to look at the replay
but guerrero looks as if he knows he's
out
well you have to check if you're charlie
montoya the manager
but chapman a little too quick
you got to go and cut off
with your legs guerrero jr
you got to go right at him he gives it
up almost too quick and bounces it to
gary so give sanchez tremendous credit
here he's got to pick it and make a good
throw at third and yes he's out boy
that's close
it's worth a look but
great job by gary sanchez not a good job
by chapman he almost blew that play
let's see what they say
it stands so the yankees have one out to
go to win their second in a row
they have a 3-2 lead
first and second two men out
and the batter is lourdes guriel it'll
be a 2-2 to guriel
fly ball center field
[Applause]
somehow he got out of it
second and third nobody out and the
yankees win 3-2 and they've taken the
first two games of this series in
buffalo